Allah says if you ask for a Allah gives
you a and both. So our main goal should
be aka even if it is 100% aka no problem
dunya will come as a byproduct you know
byproduct and I'll give you example in
the end of my talk. You do only for a
Allah will give you dunya without
fail. But if you do only for dunya your
a is
gone. And this dunya as compared to a is
very small. Average human being lives
for about 70 75
years. Some may die early 50 years 40
years. Some may die 90 100 not more than
that
110 compared to a
eternal.
So here
Allah is telling that
lucrative is profitable in
Akra. You are a better businessman.
People only want a
small. Even if your problem for this 70
years, 80 years, no problem. Akara is
eternal. A better businessman will
target the
Akara. A
A is
apt
apt. It should
be
apt and it should be
correct. If the goal that you're doing
is apt as per Quran sunnah, it's
perfect. M is measurable. You should be
able to measure
it. Not just big. For example, someone
says, "I want to build the tallest
building in the world." Okay, it's a
specific goal. Tallest building in the
world. Is it measurable? Yes. Which is
the tallest building today in the world?
It is Bourj
Khalifa. 823 m. So you have
measurable. If you anything you make
more than 823 m, it will become the
tallest building in the world.
Measurable.
I
intention. What should your intention
be to achieve the goal? Your intention
should be only and only to please Allah.
Your intention should not be that you
know people will praise me so that I
become famous.
If this is your
intention in the your goal is not
useful. Your intention should only be to
please Allah and follow the commandments
of Allah. If your intention is to please
Allah, Allah will take care of
you. And the last is C. That's
consistent. Be consistent. For example,
you plan that I want to read the
complete Quran. Okay, I'll do it in the
month of Ramadan. So you plan I will
read one every day one juice one par. So
in 30 days of
Ramadan you finish 30 Jews 30 part of
the full Quran you're
consistent. If the goal is time bound
then you be consistent till the goal is
finished. Some goal are not time bound.
For example you say I want to read the
Quran daily. Okay fine I will daily read
halfjus that is 10 pages every day be
consistent
forever our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said when aisha may
Allah be pleased with
her it's mentioned
hadith of say
Muslim point number one hadith number
1711 may Allah be pleased with ask the
prophet that what is the best of the
things the prophet is The best is the
best that is beloved to Allah is a thing
that a person does consistently even if
it is
small. Allah loves those things that are
done
consistently even if they are
small rather than doing one time big
thing. Allah likes those things which
are consistently and regular even if it
is small.
Consistent. So this is the acronym
Islamic better than the management gurus
who talk about smart.